wir haben erden immunität wenn
mindestens 60 prozent der bevölkerung
geimpft ist ist er ich bin der festen
überzeugung also nach meiner meinung
wird das also vor der sommerpause sein
dass wir dieses ziel erreicht haben
ich hoffe sogar schneller geht weil halt
auch produktionskapazitäten erhöht
werden bei montech hat in marburg eine
neue produktionsanlage eröffnet das was
also herr lindner fordert das ist alles
schon auf den weg gebracht die zahlen
heute zeigen dass also die
impfbereitschaft in den
pflegeeinrichtungen und auch vom
pflegepersonal von den pflegebedürftigen
hoch ist 90 prozent 70 prozent und
deshalb glaube ich dass wir auf der
einen seite von der logistik her von der
produktion her zügig vorankommen und von
der impfbereitschaft her auf